no matter how violent depraved or
overtly sexual a video game is rallying
the public in an effort to censor a
title will always bring more attention
to the game in question if you tell the
gaming audience that they can't play a
game they're going to want to play it so
tell your folks here are a few examples
when video games censorship went very
wrong death race if you think public
outrage of the video games is a modern
thing think again
XE DS death race is a 1976 arcade title
in which players zoom around a black and
white screen running over stick figures
to gain points officially the creatures
are gremlins but there's little
difference between a monster and a
normal human being
in the space of a few pixels death race
wasn't anything special but once The
Associated Press ran an article about it
weirdly comparing the games digital
beeps to the scream of a child it was
off to the digital races after that
various articles denounced the game as
sync and morbid and called for its
removal from arcades the end result
death race alt very very well and in
1976 Exedy made three million thanks to
death race alone Exedy released games
until 1989 and violent video games we're
here to stay mortal kombat way back in
the early 90s Nintendo controlled 90% of
the United States video game market but
it had a powerful rot Sega managed to
create a unique niche for itself by
promoting their 16-bit Sega Genesis as a
more mature edgier product than the
Super Nintendo which was portrayed as a
family-friendly toy enter the
notoriously bloody fighting game modern
combat
hey win
after a successful arcade release both
Nintendo and Sega had to make a choice
when it came to their console additions
to censor or not to censor Sega went for
blood albeit in a roundabout way with an
easy-to-remember cheat code to unlock
the game's gore but Nintendo kept it
clean
[Applause]
as a result the Genesis's version of
MORTAL KOMBAT salt more copies than its
nintendo cousin inadvertently proving
Sega's point the Genesis really was the
system to usher in the next era of
gaming night trap
there's only one reason you've heard of
Knight run and it's not because the 1992
full motion video game is any good in
1993 when the United States Senate held
a hearing about the effects of video
games on players politicians singled out
knight crap and mortal kombat as
particularly egregious examples of video
game violence the second game is night
trap which is a game set in a sorority
house the object is to keep hooded men
from hanging the young woman from a hook
complaints from parents followed and
Sega pulls night trap from store shelves
right before Christmas promising to
release a censored version down the line
but instead of keeping the contents
under wraps the Senate hearings boosted
the game's profile on a national scale
when night wrap came out for PC and Mac
in 1994 digital pictures specifically
used the controversy as a selling point
the real kicker the ESRB which was
founded as a direct response to these
Senate hearings rated the upcoming night
trap remaster t13 appropriate for plays
13 and up mana Rockstar Games is
well-acquainted with controversy being
the folks behind the Grand Theft Auto
series and all but despite critics
claims Grand Theft Auto doesn't force
you to run over hookers or innocent
pedestrians for the most part the only
people that you have to kill are other
criminals rockstars manhunt is different
speaking to games radar a former rock
star employee revealed the game's
troubled history revealing that company
employees threatened to mutiny because
of the game's excessively violent
content saying with GTA we always had
the excuse that the gameplay was
untethered you could play completely
ethically if you wanted manhunt daughter
just made us all feel icky it was all
about the violence and it was realistic
violence the rest of the world responded
similarly politicians introduced the
legislation to find retailers that sold
mature
the kids and after an alleged manhunt
Finn murdered a 14 year old with a
hammer mimicking one of manhunts grisly
kills some stores pulled the game
entirely
when Rockstar decided to press ahead
with an even more depraved sequel they
didn't even have to do much marketing as
the New York Times noted manhunt to has
received free publicity and media
attention it would have never enjoyed
were it not for the presumably unwitting
complicity of the Redding sports and
self-appointed media watchdogs it is
called manhunt - and we must warn you
there is nothing about this that is not
disturbing huniepop it's not just
violence that attracts senses sex is a
big problem - especially in North
America take honey pop for example a
game that fuses match-three puzzles with
a visual novel but it also asks the
player to seduce a variety of anime
women succeed and you'll not only get
down with your digital lady but you'll
also unlock some explicit illustrations
critics begrudgingly agreed that it's a
good puzzle game but at its core it's
pretty clearly cartoon porn while honey
pop is right at home among the visual
novels produced in Japan it's awfully
racy for mainstream American outlets and
it's been both banned from twitch and
heavily censored on Steam but that
controversy also generated awareness
honey pop moved around 540 thousand
copies in its edited form which isn't
bad for a niche title of course there's
a catch jolly after honey pop arrived on
Steam the games developers released a
free patch that restored the hidden
content avoiding the steam imposed
censorship after all point perverts
postal turf the difference that
censorship made for the postal franchise
is clear the first postal received
mediocre reviews and didn't make much of
an impact aside from an attempted ban
championed by Senator Joe Lieberman its
sequel postal 2 spawned a feature film
spin-off Berg sales records and
continues to receive expansion packs and
new content from its developer even
though the game is 15 years old so or
change the New Zealand government
succeeded in banning postal 2 on the
grounds that the gamers desire
and has the capacity to allow the
players to test how much violence and
humiliation he or she can inflict on
human beings Australia refused to
certify the game effectively making it
illegal in the country the Swedish
government tried and failed to sue
postal to local distributor for selling
violent content all of these things just
ended up promoting the game postal 2
even received an expansion pack in 2015
and a modern remaster of the first game
arrived in 2016
plans for postal 4 are reportedly
underway and if history is any
indication it will freak out people all
over again thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you love to
[Music]